you've recently said that you're a
conservative leaning
i mean maybe that's a day-to-day thing
um maybe you can push back but
uh so you have somebody like your friend
john mcwhorter
uh who you could say is uh on your left
yeah to the left of you and then you
have somebody like um
uh
thomas sold who
maybe is un
to the right of you yeah probably uh and
yet there's a lot of overlap between the
three of you right so to what degree
does politics affect
your view on race
in america
and maybe to what degree does your
view on race affect your politics
okay and that for people who don't know
has shifted over time
you've been on quite a roller coaster
as anybody who thinks about the world
should be
well
let's begin with the fact that i
was trained as an economist
in a tradition of
what many people would call
neo-liberalism i was trained at mit
which was not
a right-wing place by any means
but it was a place
where
you learned about markets
and about the benefits of
uh capitalism as a way of organizing
society
the virtues of free enterprise
the fact that the pursuit of profit was
not necessarily a bad thing but it well
might be
the road to prosperity and to economic
growth the idea that private property
and individuals seeking to acquire and
succeeding in acquiring wealth
did create inequality but it also
created opportunity and it also expanded
our knowledge and our control over uh
the physical environment which were
embedded in etc
um
so we were not marxists
uh at mit although we did read marx i
mean those of us who are intellectually
curious you read marks marx was an
important
figure in the history of the west and i
think marx should be read and capital
three volumes etc
uh alienation of labor uh and whatnot
the implications of modernization of the
advent of industrial capitalism et
cetera that that kind of dynamic
uh deserves to be studied and to come at
it in a critical way
informed by the intellectual inheritance
of marx and marxism i think that's a
part of a full education in social
philosophy and and uh economic analysis
that a open-minded person ought to
acquaint themselves with but at the end
of the day i think that the
uh
i think that the free marketeers have
the better of it
i think the story of the 20th century as
far as economic development is
concerned uh reflects that i think that
the experiments where uh centralized
control over
economic decisions
was the order of the day
failed
uh i think that the
fact of the 21st century rise of china
as a force has a lot to do with the
spread of in effect
capitalist oriented modes of entering
economic uh exchange freeing up prices
markets property uh and so forth
although obviously it's a complicated
political economic system i'm talking
about china
um but uh i think that the uh story of
the 20th century and the hope for the
21st century is that
prosperity is enhanced through the
free exchange of goods and the pursuit
and acquisition of property uh by people
in a more or less
capitalist oriented
uh
system that that's you know that's the
view that i hold i guess that makes me a
conservative i don't know
i want to say
that's not to the exclusion of a social
safety net i'm not saying that old
people
in an ideal social system would be left
to their own devices regardless of
whether or not they had saved for their
retirement i'm not saying that
uh the ideal of extending decent access
to health care to all people regardless
of whether or not they can afford it
decent access to education to people
regardless of whether or not they can
afford it is standing in the way of
prosperity i don't believe that i think
the mixed economies that we see in
northern europe and in north america
uh are a balancing
of the virtues of free enterprise
property and the pursuit of wealth on
the one hand
against
the needs to have a decent society in
which people who fall between the cracks
nevertheless
are
bolstered through a sense of social
solidarity
that is accommodated by our common
membership within a single
nation state which is why i think
nationalism is important and it's why i
think borders are important because
without a coherent
polity who can
uh see themselves as in a common
situation and
agree through their politics to support
each other to some extent you can't
sustain a safety net you cannot you
cannot have a social safety net for a
global population you can only have a
social safety net for a bounded
population who have a sense of common
membership
in
an ongoing political enterprise which
they pay their dues through their taxes
in order to sustain it there's a
balancing that has to go on so that's
the first thing that i would say about
my politics
i'm a neo-liberal economist i believe in
markets i believe in prices i believe in
profit
corporations are not an incarnation of
evil
corporations are a legal nexus through
which
production gets organized in which you
solicit the cooperation of workers of
people who provide capital of people who
provide raw materials and input of
customers uh and so on and that
functionality
allows for
the production of goods and their
distribution and the earning of income
and its distribution
which at the end of the day is the
foundation of our prosperity
corporations are people too mitt romney
got in trouble for saying that in 2012.
but corporations are nothing but illegal
fiction the corporation is not a person
as such
but the nexus of contracts and
relationships amongst the stakeholders
who intersect in the
context of the corporation is the way in
which we organize the massively complex
set of activities that are necessary in
order to produce
economic uh
benefits in order to feed people in
order to have everybody with a cell
phone in their pocket in order to be
able to travel from one side of a
continent to another on a device that is
with almost absolute certainty going to
safely take off
in land and in order to be able to build
cities and it's etc but do the markets
the ideal of the market collide with the
ideal of all men are created equal
the identity the struggle that we've
been talking about of
of what it means to sort of empower
humans that make up this great country
do they collide and where do they
collide well markets are going to
produce inequality
and
all men being equal is a statement about
the intrinsic worth of people
not about the situation that will come
about when people interact with each
other through markets because people are
actually different
and because there are factors that are
beyond anybody's control called luck and
chance that you know you and i both
invest
it looked our priority like your
investment in my investment were equally
likely to succeed but as a matter of
fact x post facto your investment
succeeds my investment doesn't succeed
i don't have wealth and you have wealth
that is an inevitable consequence of a
environment in which both of us are free
to make our investment choices
and where the consequences of investment
depend in part upon
random circumstances over which no one
has control
but you asked me about my politics and i
was just trying to lay down a foundation
by saying i begin
as an economist in the tradition of uh
liberalism adam smith and so forth john
maynard keynes for that matter and so
forth
uh that um
milton friedman and so forth
that
paul samuelson bob solo
uh james tobin uh
and so forth
uh thomas soul yes
uh that appreciates property
the virtues of free
enterprise uh the
set of institutions that allow for
a security of contract a rule of law
things of this kind
so that's one thing to say about my
politics
another thing to say about my politics
and you're right i've moved around
is that you know i began south side of
chicago black kid i was a liberal
democrat
um
i
encountered uh the economics curriculum
at the mit and i i became trained in
economics in the tradition that i've
just described
uh
and i encountered uh also
the reagan revolution this is the late
70s and early 80s
these are big debates about economic
policy and so on
um and
i found a lot to admire uh in the supply
ciders
uh the people were saying you know let's
get the government out of the way the
people who are worried about national
debt which is a lot more now than it was
then
the people were worried that the welfare
state could be too big that the
incentives of transfer programs could be
counterproductive that you had a war on
poverty and we did have a war on poverty
and poverty won and there's a lot of
evidence that the war on poverty was
lost by the people who were trying to
quote unquote eradicate poverty in our
time
um
that uh incentives really do matter and
that the state
which is driven by politics is often
unresponsive to the dictates of
incentives whereas markets
eliminate people who are inefficient who
are not cognizant of the consequences of
incentives because they can't cover
their bottom line and they won't persist
for very long if they can't cover their
bottom line they're forced to respond to
the realities of differences in costs
and benefits and so forth in a way that
governments can cover because they have
their hand in our pocket
they can cover their losses and they can
make accounts balanced notwithstanding
their mistakes because they can take my
property by fiat by the power of the
state the tax collector comes if i don't
pay he seizes my holdings
and uh they can uh carry on in that way
they need the corrective influence of
markets in order to be responsive to the
realities of life i mean i may not like
it
that uh prices are
telling me that something that i want to
do is infeasible i may not like it but
what the prices are telling me is that
the costs of doing it
exceed the benefits to be derived from
doing it and if i persist in doing it
notwithstanding that i'm going to run
losses and those losses will accumulate
and the net effect of that over an
entire society
is stagnation
and ultimate attenuation of the economic
benefits that might be available to
people again i think if you look at the
developing world
in the post-colonial period the second
half of the 20th century that's exactly
what you see
planning doesn't work
centralized control over resource
allocation doesn't work okay so
i became more conservative in that
respect but i also and this has to do
with race
lost the faith
in
the
posture
that uh beca what became of the civil
rights movement i mean the civil rights
movement you quote king 1963 the civil
rights movement starts out as
um
we want equal membership in the polity
but it becomes
uh
a a a a
a
systematized
a cover
i'm going to argue
for deficiencies that are
uh discernible within black american
society which only we could correct
that's a very controversial statement
uh i i make it with trepidation i i
don't take any pleasure in saying it
but here's what i'm talking about
so i'm talking about the family
so the family
is a matter
internal
to the community about how men and women
relate to each other
and engage in social reproduction child
bearing
uh the standing up of households
the context within which children are
developed are maturing and so forth and
so on so the african-american family is
in trouble i think i can demonstrate
that by reference to
high rates of marital dissolution
uh
by high rates of birth to uh out of
wedlock and so forth
you can't even say that the
african-american family is in trouble
violence
homicide is the order of magnitude more
prevalent amongst african americans than
it is in the society as a whole
this is behavior it's behavior of our
people i speak of black people of course
we're not the only people in society for
whom violence is an issue it's an order
of magnitude
more prevalent
uh in our communities i'm talking about
schooling and school failure
so we have affirmative action as a cover
it's a band-aid on differences in the
development of intellectual performance
which is only partly a consequence of
the natural intelligence of people and
largely a consequence of how people
spend their time what they value
how they discipline themselves what they
do with their
opportunities how parents raise their
children what peer groups value and
things of this kind the asian students
who are scoring off the charts on these
exams
are doing it not because they're
intrinsically more intelligent to other
people but because they work harder
because their parents are more insistent
on focusing on their intellectual
performance because they're disciplined
uh because of the way that they devote
their time and their resources to uh
equipping their children to function in
the 21st century this is what i believe
i think it's demonstrably the case
and it is a factor in racial disparity
the way that the civil rights movement
has evolved under the wing of the
democratic party
into an organized appalachia
uh of for the failures of african
americans to seize the opportunities
that exist for us now in the 21st
century but did not exist
in the first half of the 20th century
the way in which the civil rights
movement has become
an avoidance mechanism
for us not taking we african-americans
responsibly this is glenn lowry not
everybody's going to agree with it
uh is part of what makes me
a conservative i am tired of the
bellyaching i'm tired of the excuse me
white supremacy
uh it is in my mind
a joke
uh i lament the fact that that kind of
rhetoric
is so seductively
attractive to african americans and so
widely adopted
by others
and
as i am fond of saying at the end of the
day nobody is coming to save us
i mean
higher education
mit caltech stanford
the where the future is happening
that is about mastery over
the achievements of human civilization
such as they manifest themselves in the
21st century there's no substitute for
actually acquiring mastery
over the material there's no substitute
for that
to be
uh patronized
to have the standards lower they want to
get rid of the test
they want to tell african americans that
pat us on the head
uh we're going to have a separate
program for you we're going to give you
a side door that you can come into that
doesn't make us any smarter
it doesn't make us any more creative
um and it doesn't make us any more fit
for the actual competition that's
unfolding before us
now
you want to be 10 of the population
that's carried along for the next 100
years you want to be
uh a ward of the state in the late 21st
century you go ahead because the chinese
are coming
you're not going to hold them back the
world is being remade every decade by
new ways of seeing and new ways of doing
if you don't get on board with the
dynamic advancement of the civilization
in which we are embedded you're going to
end up being dependent on other people
to look kindly upon you in this story
that you've got this uh bellyache
this excuse my ancestors were slaves
it's only going to
work
for so long
so that's that makes me i suppose
a kind of conservatives i hate
affirmative action i don't just disagree
with it i don't just think it's
against the 14th amendment i hate it
the hatred comes from an understanding
that it is a band-aid that it is a
substitute for the actual development
over the capacities of our people to
compete
i'd much rather be in the position
of having them try to keep me out
because i'm so damn good like they're
doing with the asians
then having them have to beg the supreme
court to allow for a special
dispensation on my behalf because they
need
diversity and inclusion and belonging
it's not just diversity it's not just
diversity and inclusion there's
diversity and inclusion and belonging
i'm whining because i feel like i don't
belong
that's a position of weakness it's
pathetic
and it's only political correctness that
keeps people who can see this and
believe me a lot of people can see it
from saying so out loud
so you want
the black american community to
represent strength
correct and i want us to deal with what
it is that we have to deal with in order
to be able to
project strength
uh in in an increasingly competitive
world
you